hello everyone and welcome to Game eight
of the 2018 World Chess Championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Caruana what everyone was hoping to see
today was some crazy refutation of the
rosalie Manoj Medina attack where we
will see that or not
we're just gonna have to wait and see
Fabiana has the white pieces and we're
gonna dive straight into the game but as
usual we do have some very interesting
photos compliments of niki riga once
again so let's check it out and also we
will use the first one as a photo
challenge surely you know the gentleman
who makes the first move for Fabi but
just in case some of you are perhaps new
to the channel or to the chess world it
will be come as a very nice exercise so
who is the gentleman making the first
move for Fabi some not not maybe a year
ago but some six to eight months ago we
have enjoyed some very nice game by the
self learning AI alpha zero and he
definitely had something to do with it
so there's a little bit of a hint for
you also we have a very nice handshake
between Carlson and Caruana before the
start of the game
chief arbitral author Schmidt again
towering over them and here we have a
very nice photo of course and making his
first move as black and yes it will be
again a Sicilian and since this is the
fourth Sicilian we see this is game
eight and in every game cora wanna play
d for every game cost and defender would
see five so this is Sicilian defense I
thought it you know I thought it might
be a bit funny be first to win ce6
and then only proceed to see five like
the little joke towel played against the
young Fischer as you know Carmona is an
American Challenger but you know it's
the Watchers championship match maybe
not the greatest time for jokes but you
know in case he will repeat it in game
10 you know maybe just a little nudge to
c6 and then C 5 who knows might be might
be very nice and also our here we have
also an excellent photo you can see the
sharp red color of course and socks that
goes very nicely with the Norwegian flag
on the left there we have it Korona not
not seeming all that interested in
taking a photo a burqa enough with the
photos let's dive straight into the game
like we said we have efore c5 caution
goes for the Sicilian Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and here well we've already
seen three Rosalie Mo's with Bishop to
b5 here karana actually goes for the
main B for the open Sicilian and
everyone was very happy when they saw
this we didn't know we were will we see
a knight of what we see some crazy align
a so let's see what they played see
captors on d4 Knight captures on d4 and
now comes Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
now II five the Lasker variation Knight
the b5 and here the most games available
in the database continuing with a six
this would be the main line not the main
line but not something that you want to
play as black because here Knight to d6
is definitely a possibility and here
black would have to part with his bishop
pair yeah so here even if you you
exchange everything it's hard to say if
white actually has something but the
bishop pair will certainly be a great
advantage in such an open game so uh we
have d6 this is the main line and now
comes Knight to d5 also possible is
Bishop to g5 a move that is very
frequently played and then after a
six-night 283 b5 also a favorite a line
amongst those who play in the Lasker
variation so after d6 we have Knight to
d5 now threatening of course Knight to
c7 check this pawn is not free for grabs
I who captured then you are quickly
getting checkmate at night b7 check
after you move the King or you can give
up your queen but doesn't really matter
Queen g4 check at five Queen captures on
a5 this will be checkmate of course
nothing like this is likely to happen in
World Chess Championship match so
tonight captures on d5 and here we have
pawn captures attacking the knight and
now comes Knights to be eight this is
still all a standard theory of this
opening and here c4 is a move that can
be found in a lot of games in the
database but what Kerwin and his team
prepared for this game is actually a for
a much
a much less played move in this
variation but still amongst the engine's
favorites Bishop to e7 Carlson is
preparing to Castle we have Bishop to e2
across and castles Caruana castles and
now comes Knight to d7
we have Bishop to b2 and this seems like
a very very passive setup for a while
but it's actually pretty great as you'll
see the the Bishop pearl defends the a5
square karana will want to pull this
pawn to e5 so one course and finally
dislodge the knife from be [ __ ] then I
can actually go to a3 and the bishop
will defend the pawn that will be an a5
so f5 here by Carlsen and this is not a
new move in the position but a very rare
move here grigory operand had this
position in 2017 and again the Boris
Gelfand and in this position gave and
was known to play nice to have six in
that game he drew his game against
operand in one game if he tried a six
but those were both the rapid games and
in the game he played a six opening
action but the beadboard is getting on
but here across and goes for f5 a very
nice expansion and karana proceeds
simply with his plan a5 and there is one
game available in the database where
nice to have six was played that ended
in a draw but here we have a six and
this is now completely a new game
already on move 13 that was never played
before
nice - a3 as planned now the Queen
cannot capture as a Cohen as Bishop is
guarding the e5 pawn and we have E 4 by
Carlsen grabbing even more space in the
center and making room for this night to
be able to come to e5 Knight to c4 by
Caruana a very nice square for the
knight controlling very important
central squares but also preparing to
jump to b6 this is very important and
one of the reasons the pawn needed to
come to a five-night the e5 and now
comes night the b6 also if you capture
here then D captures and the black's
pawn mass in the center will be simply
too powerful if C 4 F 4 is coming and
black will just have a very enjoyable
game but here karana goes for nights the
six attacking Carlson's rockin a 8 and
Crossin moves it there's really no other
move rook debate was played but I did
try to make a little joke on Twitter I
said that f4 would have been a very
interesting move but it might be an
interesting move if white actually
captures the rook immediately then would
have three you could perhaps have an
interesting game of course not not in a
serious competition but here after white
goes back Bishop g4 pawn captures pawn
captures and after Bishop to d3 Queen to
e8 and now it would be very hard for
black in a practical game to actually
prevent such nasty threats here
let's see King h1 you want to get the
rook back over to g1 after Bishop d3
room do you want Queen h5 and it would
be a very tough position for whites to
hold you know in top competition I I
believe black would be able to prevail
here problem is after f4 white can
simply capture the pawn and I mean after
rule captures now capture the night and
now there is no attack and you just gave
up well you didn't give up but you give
up an exchange and white will simply be
much better but still you know an
interesting idea
so after Knight to be six rook to b8
Carson of course it doesn't want to part
2 it is rook we have f4 attacking the
knight on e5 as that's a very strong
square of course you don't want to move
the knight we have a captures on f3 on
pass on Bishop captures on f3 and here
across and spent a lot of time there was
discussion about playing f4 here simply
making the room for this Bishop to come
to f5 as you don't want this tension to
always be present here you do want to
develop this bishop and somehow get this
rocker into the game as long as the
knight is and b6 this rook really isn't
going anywhere but here after some 13
minutes of thinking Carson played g5 a
very nice move and it seems like a very
committal move so now you will either
start attacking and win the game or you
will pretty much suffer for the rest of
the game and it's very interesting that
after Carson played g5 Caruana simply
blitzed out c4 which is very very tough
to deal with if you play such a
committal move you
to your opponent you know to take it
very hard psychologically you want him
to spend time you know decide oh can i
play c4 if he pushes g4 and you know
things like that but here corona simply
played c4 and I imagine Coulson was very
upset by this because now if g4 is
played Caruana obviously came prepared
and prepared c-4 in home analysis
because now if g4 Bishop to e2 okay
Bishop g5 you want to get to the Queen
into the game and perhaps start pushing
your pawns but should capture screen
captures but now you have Queen to c1
you offer a queen trait and black can't
really offer a queen trade
so after f4 c5 you still can push f3
because the Queen is unguarded when g5
Queen to f6 and now c6 captures captures
and now this pawn will be very strong
if f3 you can simply capture it or
perhaps the Bishop c4 first and ID
captures Queen captures with check and
after Bishop to e6 you will move back
the Queen but now black has no ways no
way of actually pushing anything or
capturing anything and White's C pawn is
simply a monster so obviously there at
the end this is one of the best lines
there there exists for white all the
other lines are simply much better for
white so karana definitely came prepared
with the c-4 move and Carson was forced
to play f4 so making room for his bishop
to come to a5
we have Bishop the c3 here and this
Bishop the c3 move is the first to move
most likely that Caruana made over the
board as it took him some 10 minutes to
make this move perhaps it was still you
know a glimpse of home preparation but
he just wanted not perhaps blitz it out
or for some reason he spent some time on
it but it's it was actually his first
thinking move if you go for something
like Bishop to g4 would ideas of Queen
to h5 then black can immediately counter
it with Bishop to a5 captures captures
and now if Queen better to c3
it will be a similar position to what
happened in the game but you don't want
to make it easy for black you want the
blacks light square Bishop to stay on c8
and really hinder his development so
after a for Bishop the c3 immediately by
Caruana the move he spent his first time
on and here Carson spent some 20 minutes
and played Bush of to f5 and here Carson
was spending so long and Kerwin was
bleeding out all of his moves that by
this time in the game it's moved 20
Caruana was already a whole hour up on
the clock so across him was a in serious
time trouble here and after Carson
played Bishop to a5 there was really no
other way for whites to make any
progress but to push c5 and there was
this whole argument over the entire
injured internet where whether c5 should
be pushed ideas like c5 and then if
black captures immediately d6 and a lot
of ideas were happening here and
obviously Caruana
did feel that this was his moment to
strike as it was in this moment that
Caruana actually took off his jacket and
you know he was you really started to
thinking and it took him some 33 minutes
to play his next move and it is exactly
why for example say say the Norwegian
supercomputer didn't like Bishop to a5
said that the Queen to c7 was in fact
better going after the c4 pawn and
preventing c5 but okay you know that's
just say say after Bishop to a5 Caruana
did play c5 and this is the strongest
way to proceed but like we like I said
it did take him some 33 minutes to play
this because you have to take a lot of
things into consideration like if you
push c5 can cross and actually push g4
what happens if he pushes g4 Bishop to
e2 then f3 is coming
what happens now G captures we have G
captures and now after Bishop captures
Bishop to h3 is black actually having a
meeting attack here bushra blocks
worship captures team captures and now
it's very hard to continue the attack
here ro captures Queen captures and
black simply doesn't have any pieces to
attack with the only rook black has is
stuck on b8 Queen f8 you can simply
capture on e5 and after bone captures d6
and it's actually white that's much
better
and even winning this game so Caruana
calculates everything precisely ac5 and
excellent move and Carlsen blitzes out
Knight captures on f3 so he was prepared
for this we have Queen captures on f3
and now comes D captures on c5 and here
where everyone thought that well
everyone there was a lot of a lot of
questioning going on whether we want to
bring this rook over to e1 whether we
want to bring this rook over to e1 what
the general consensus was that you want
at least one rook anyone as a regardless
of this bishop controlling this diagonal
bringing a rook over to the e-file and
making this Knight
nice Brooke lifts the e6 would be very
hard to defend in a practical game for
example if rook 81 a move suggested by
sesay it would be very hard for black to
actually play this with the best defense
Bishop to f6 h 4 Bishop captures Queen
captures and now you would have pawn
captures on h4 in Queen captures on c5
you would have this very nice pass pawn
on d5 and it would be very dangerous if
this rook ever comes to e7 you can
double up on the e-file and create all
sorts of threats here but it would out a
perfect defense for black against this
rook 81 move for example you play Bishop
to d6 and then ideas even like Queen to
h5 are possible rook to f7 and now even
Luke to e6 sacrificing the exchange
where you would never be able to capture
this rook white would just be able to
double up or simply try increasing the
pressure because if you captures and
pawn captures then there's a really no
way to defend it
rook the c7 only square where you can go
to night simply attacks it and it's
simply too much there there's no defense
against Knight to f6 check which would
force you to go over to the bishops
diagonal and if you move the rook from
the seventh rank something like rook to
see it then even Queen to f7 the
immediate checkmate is available so it
would be very very hard to defend
against such a move especially with such
little time on the clock but who knows
because up until up until this point
Carson was basically playing against
an engine that Kiwanis team he basically
faced lines that Cronus team prepared
using a supercomputer so definitely
strong player or magnus carlsen
and that's why i decided to use this
title i don't know seems it seemed like
an appropriate thing to do but here
quran actually played rook a to d1 and
this was somewhat odd okay you are
threatening to pull d6 but now Carson
just immediately blocks it and here
again there's a you're still better as
white of course the the rook is stuck
here black doesn't really have all that
many options but if Black gets a couple
of moves in like Queen e8 Queen g6 and
manages to push d4 it will be very
dangerous for white so here were a move
that was again expected from Caruana
either getting this rook to e1 or the
immediate Queen to h5 would result in a
couple of interesting positions for
example Bishop to g6 kicking the Queen
away Queen to h6 threatening checkmate
already rook to f7 blocking and now rook
after he won its it was so crucial that
there is at least one of the rooks on
the e-file Bishop to f8 kicking the
Queen away Queen to h3 now kicking the
Queen further away Queen to h5 Bishop to
d6 but now Queen to f3 and now after you
prevent d6 as you don't really want to
allow these six Bishop to d6 now comes
Knight to c4 and after white eliminates
this Bishop white will be the only
player with a dark square bishop and it
will be simply too much white will have
so much control over the entire game it
would most likely be a winning attack
for white but here to everyone's
surprise Cora wanna actually played h3
and as they've mentioned in the press
conference after the game in cousin was
super relieved when he saw this H
removed as he immediately played Queen
to d8 and now it's actually white that
has to be careful if cross and manages
to get Queen g6 and the g4 in then black
will start a very dangerous attack so
here after some 12 minutes
Khurana decides that he cannot simply
allow this Knight
ceefor displayed going after the dark
square bishop and now cousin must part
him with his dark square Bishop queen g6
we have night captures on these six
Queen captures and now again you don't
want to allow black to consolidate with
something like rook e8 and then perhaps
even some ideas if you manage to to get
the pawns rolling on the King side again
it could be very dangerous for white so
here H for deciding to to remove the
defender of the f4 pawn and going for an
ice queen exchange bringing the rook
over to D file now is a bit too late
because black will simply counter your
rook which is inactive rook and now I
mean the roofs are just getting off
along the e-file and nothing is
happening here so Corona tried h4 now we
have G captures on h4 Queen captures on
f4 Queen captures rook captures and now
a very nice move by Carlsen h5 a
beautiful move that basically says that
if you capture my pawn here I'm just
gonna trap your rook and not trap it in
a sense that he will capture it and a
time soon but it will take this rook a
very long time to actually reenter the
game so after h5 we have rook back to
rook to e1 and now comes Bishop to g4
simply not allowing the rook to capture
on h4 n anymore and offering a trade of
rooks rook to f6 has the bishop is
controlling the rub rook captures Bishop
captures and now King to f7 we have
Bishop to h4 capturing the pawn rook to
e8 and now call a Khurana doesn't want
to immediately go into the endgame of
opposite called bishops a but first look
to f1 check we have King to g8 and now
comes Luke to f6 here
Khurana wants to go after these pawns
but it's very unlikely cross and goes
for the active defense rook to e2 we
have blue g6 check King to f8 and now
comes even d6
going after the pawns now doesn't really
do all that much because you can simply
prevent it disrupt the c8 you defend the
pawn and if route goes back Bishop goes
back to g4 nothing is really happening
here there is no way to exploit these
two weaknesses and
I don't know if there's no way to
exploit them there they aren't really
weaknesses so after King to f8 d6
pushing the past pawn but now rook the D
to Carlsen simply puts his rook behind
the past pawn as that's what you always
want to do when there's a passport here
you could actually blunder if you play
something like King to f7 and attack the
rook because then White would have rook
captures on g4 it would be very
unfortunate for an for a game to end
like this because after pawn captures
the d7 is coming notice that the bishop
is controlling the d8 square and now
after you block it you get a queen rook
captures Bishop captures this will
simply be winning for white now so after
rook to e2 sorry after d6 looked at me -
and now comes roof to g5 and it was in
this position that the players agreed to
a draw unmoved 38 before even reaching
time control as now ok the c5 pawn is
under attack
c4 rook attacks that captures captures
and now we basically have equal material
on the board with opposite colored
bishops and there's not all that much
you can do here to even try anything
both of the players know this so like we
said after rook to g5 they agree to a
draw and game number 8 and in the draw
the result is not 4 to 4 we have 4 more
games to go before we reach the faster
time controls so four more games in the
classical and I don't know it seems
cousin really dodged a very nice bullet
here but really huge congratulations the
Carson has like we said up until move 20
so up until this point where Corona
played Bishop to c3 up until this point
Carson was basically down a whole hour
on the clock and basically he was
playing against an engine so now I hear
when really you should have unleashed
creativity and go for something like
rook to e1 there it simply wasn't
possible so again we have this huge
question or is it just trying to create
winning chances straight out of the
opening with preparations do the engines
really
kill your creativity is there is there
no way around it simply I I see this
game as a win for Magnus because it's
hard to hard to actually look at it
otherwise but I don't know at least the
in-game ten if we see another Sicilian I
hope Carson will try the little C 6 C 5
joke but yeah how did you enjoy this
game how do you do you enjoy the
championship so far and what's your
overall impression of the entire of the
entire event I would like to thank Adam
meet Frank Lamar Jr Lonardo de queirós
Fionna Braga Niels Lindbergh and Andrew
McCrea for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
games and big announcement even charge
of Croatia has just reached her 2,700
rating for the first time in his life
he's the first player from Croatia to
ever achieve such such a rating it was
in his game against Japan of so big
congratulations to him I'll see if I if
I manage as tomorrow is the rest day
perhaps we can even see a very nice game
from that event so thank you all and I
will see you soon